hello everyone and good morning everyone
I thought I'd do this game yesterday
right after it was finished but I was
really tired and decided I'd do it
straight in the morning and it's a good
thing I did since I have a lot of nice
photos from the candidates and from this
game to share with you guys I have the
photos I contacted Nicki reader she's a
photographer and she will be at the
candidates everyday so for this video
and every other video I will do about
the candidates we will be able to enjoy
some nice photos so this is Nicki that's
her on the right would magnus carlsen
and if you enjoyed chess if you enjoy
photos if you enjoy chest photography
feel free to follow her I will put all
of the links to our social media in the
description below so you can enjoy some
more chest photos in the future so let's
see this game it's Vladimir Kramnik with
the white pieces against Fabiano Caruana
here we have them this is right before
the game and the first move is being
made the e4 pawn lounges forward and
here we have Fabiano Caruana considering
what to do in the opening so as I will
use a couple of more photos as they're
really enjoyable let's first see the
game so chronic is definitely a feeling
alright would himself in round 3 he
defeated 11 onion with that Berlin
specialty and now he has the white
pieces against Fabiano Caruana the world
really doesn't get any better than that
so he opens with E for Fabiano replies a
5 we have Knight to f3 and 90 to f6
Fabiano goes for the petrov defense
Knight captures on e5 d six
Knight back to f3 and Knight captures on
e4 now and I will just mention here as
if you ever faced the petrov you should
know this famous trap
if white replies Knight c3 and black
tries to defend this knightwood Bishop
to a5 this loses the game immediately
for black because Queen e2 wins the
piece it seems like a trivial mistake
and the trivial trap but a lot of great
players fell for this opening even even
the great fisherman at an island because
now if you try to defend the knight of
course d3 is a threat if
Knight is defended in any way by the
pawn and if Queen to is a queen 3/7 and
Knight to d5 simply wins the game you
have to move the Queen to still defend
the c7 pawn so Queen to d8 and now d3
again wins the piece just wanted to
throw that in there but okay after
Knight to e4 Queenie to now by chronic
we have 27 and now Knight to c3 Knight
captures D captures and Queen captures
an e to Bishop captures an e2 and this
is a move 8 of the game already the
Queen's out of the board a pair of
knights is of the board and I caught a
glimpse of a live coverage on chess 24
by Gustafson and sweedler they were very
unimpressed of how kramnik was treating
this opening after that yesterday's
brilliance against Aragon he decided to
play the petrov which really doesn't
give white any edge and now you know you
have to play this position you're not
worse or anything but you that you
definitely don't have any advantage
maybe a little one in development but
nothing to be very proud of but okay
nice to see six we have Bishop to e3
Bishop to e7 and here chromic castles
Queen side and here we have a nice photo
of of this moment here you have after
kramnik matthias castle he is pouring
himself a cup of coffee and he's ready
to really play this game regardless of
how long it takes this is him after here
he had his sip of coffee now you can see
he's ready to do some battle
so here Caruana castles and rook h 2 e 1
so simply developing all the pieces
bishop to f6
we have night 2 d 2 transferring the
night rook to e8 and Bishop to F 3 9 3 5
attacking the bishop on f3 Bishop to f4
now King to f8 as the rock on e8 is
undefended Bishop to d5 we have c6
Bishop to b3 and Bishop to f5 now H 3 g5
attacking the bishop bishop to h2 and
King to g7 and here we have c4 by
chronic any other interesting decision
and so far
it's a game nothing is really happening
everyone is trying to win this square
when that square wins some more space
and here Caruana goes 4g for an
interesting move definitely will be
something like c5 maybe put a c5 early
and try to make this light square Bishop
looks silly
but then Knight to e4 simply will force
white to give up his bishop as the d6
pawn is hanging and if you try and
defend this with let's say Bishop to e7
then white can simply capture the c5
pawn as now the night will be undefended
after the pawn captures so in here
g4 by Caruana again Knight to e4 with a
double attack on the d6 pawn Bishop
captures rook captures and Bishop to g5
now with check King Tubby 1 and G
captures on h3 and this is where this is
where the game starts to get interesting
here the obvious responses G captors on
h3 and then f5 will follow and and so on
but in the game kramnik decided to go c5
he's allowing Fabiano to create a nice
pass pawn already on g2 but he will then
he will capture the pawn on d6 and
create a nice passed pawn of his own so
here first f5 as you know why not grab a
tempo first rock the b5 attacking the b7
pawn and now H captures on g2 so rook
captures on b7 this is with check King
to h8 and now seek after some d6 so now
you have this really far away past Jeep
1 and you have this well already on c6
pest C pawn but by on d6 by Kramnik so
we have Knight to f3 attacking the
bishop on h2 and here we have really the
the move of the game but there will be a
lot of great moments in the game here
chronic placed at Bishop to a4 and this
is in fact the strongest move he
sacrifices the bishop on h2 for for the
following idea Caruana isn't very
impressed by his move
captures the bishop and night captures
we have Bishop captures on c6 attacking
the rockin e8 and now rook a to d8 as
this was the idea karana had while he
captured the bishop on h2 now you can't
really capture the look if you capture
the rock then rook captures on d6 you
lose you're basically the only advantage
you had for this sacrifice the past D
pawn and now you don't really you know
you don't really have anything here
you can't of course capture the rook
then g1 is coming with checkmate so this
would be very unfavorable
so here gromek tried d7 rook to e2 we
have bishop to capture some g2 and now
rook captures an f2 attacking the bishop
bishop back to c6 and now Knight to g4
here rook captures on a7 was played 90
to e3 now attacking the rook on d1 and
rook to g1 would an attack on the bishop
on g5 h 6 protecting the bishop and now
rook to c7 you can't really capture the
pawn and c2 if you play rook captures
and sorry
after this rope to c7 now King to g7
King to g7 was played you can't capture
this pawn and c2 if you capture it then
you get rook captures on g5 and you
can't recapture the rook because rook c8
simply wins the game
so here rook captures and e7 would have
to be played but now you don't capture
the rock on d7 you first give check so
you're rockin C it will be protected
King moves and now Bishop captures after
rook captures now you play rook captures
on f5 first and now of course if you
capture then first Bishop captures with
check and only then you pick up the rook
but after work c7 rock e5 and with two
passed pawns on the Queens and the Queen
side White has white has good chances
here so at Roxy 7 of course not grabbing
the pawn first Fabi plays King to g7 and
now Kramnik starts pushing his own past
points as he does have well there are
currently three connected passed pawns
the queenside and they may very well
connect with the past deep own in the
future King King to f7 getting the king
closer to the deep on also on painting
the Bishop Bishop to b5 and here King to
e7 a5 is coming and now rook to f4 C 3
by kramnik and not allowing not allowing
rook to before to attack the bishop and
also now this really solidifies the
Kings position here as Bishop to f6 and
rook to f2 will not be that much of a
threat King to d6 attacking rockin c7
and here we have rope to b7 this King to
d6 wasn't the most precise move by Fabi
and here Kramnik if he wanted to do
maybe he saw it maybe he didn't he could
have punished it Woodroof to c6 now you
can't capture the pawn because of rook
captures on h6 this opens up our
discovered to check from the bishop and
after the King moves
simply rook captures the bishop on g5 so
you you can't really capture it after
rook to c6 check you'd have to move but
then a6 is coming
rook after 77 and now rook to c8
attacking the rook can be 7 so the rook
has to move on only good square for the
rook is actually a 7 because you have to
prevent the pawn from coming coming to a
7 so rope to a 7 and now comes this rook
to e8 check King moves and you pick up
the knight on e3 so maybe he saw this
and didn't like it maybe he didn't see
it I haven't seen the official interview
after the game maybe some of you have so
do share in the comments so rook to b7
was played by chronic and now rook to g4
offering an exchange of rooks here
rook to e1 and now F for a 6
we have h5 a7 and rook to e8 and it
seems like it's it's a it seems like a
great position for white both pawns are
already on a 7 and undie 7 but you know
yeah you have to play this very
precisely here Kramnik pushed b4 he's
preparing c4 and c5 Fabiano pushes h4 we
have c4 h 3 c 5 the
comes with check King to e5 and here
rook to b8 was played and this is a
disposition is extremely complicated and
it will definitely take you a lot of
time to calculate some ideas for example
instead of Ruby 8 it seems like a
reasonably good move is c6
I mean c7 is coming and then you can
choose like which one you want to
promote to Queen but again the c6 move
is also very complicated here h2 and now
after we play c7 now a black of course
will play rook to g1 he wants to eat or
exchange rooks and then bring your Queen
into the game or cover the h1 square and
here it's a very very complicated
position let's say you you bring the
Queen into the game then the black has
this option of capturing the rook and
after you play King to be 2 then comes
Queen to h1 and after you try something
let's say going to c5 check simply
Knight to d5 white has no more no more
checks and no more attacking ideas and
black is simply up to much material and
will win this game easily so on the
other hand after the skin to e5 move
after c6 bet and h2 like we said c7 Rock
to g1 blocking now the best idea would
be Bishop to c6
but again this would only offer a draw
the idea is after rook captures anyone
now you move the King but now black has
this very interesting resource of
playing rook to e1 check sacrificing the
rook King captures now Knight to d5
blocking the bishops defense of the h1
square so now Bishop capture screen
captures and now let's say we bring the
Queen into the game now Fabi will bring
his own queen in the game with check
King moves and now however you play this
out it will be a repetition and the draw
even if the bishop comes to help with
the attack you could give a couple of
more checks even if you go Queen a to
check still the king is very safe and b5
so after the skin - if I move a
crumbling decided to go for rook to b8
he
to give up his a 7.4 for some activity
so rook captures on a 7
we have rook to g8 the threat of course
being rook captures on g5 and promoting
to a queen here Bishop to f6 not
allowing it and here
d8 Queen so now you have to pick up the
queen of course Bishop captures rook
captures on g4 and Bishop to f6
we have looked roof to g6 rook to b7
attacking the bishop bishop moves and
now rook captures some before king to a2
and now Knight the c2 attacking the rook
on e 1r up the C one night to d4 Bishop
to d3 rook to 1/4 check King to be one
and now nice to be three again attacking
the rook and c1 and also the pawn on c5
so rook to e1 check King moves and now
King to see two attacking the knight
Knight to d4 check King b1 and now
Knight to f3 again attacking the rook on
e1 and here rook to d1 was played and
rook to d1 is the decisive mistake that
cost Kramnik the game here his last hope
of maybe maintaining so maybe
maintaining a draw in this game was rook
captures on f6 and after Knight captures
anyone now Bishop to f1 attacking the h3
pawn after H 2 root 2 H 6 and after King
captures on c5 rook captures on h2 and
maybe maybe hold this position against
the past F pawn but after this night to
have to remove Kramnik plate rook to d1
here threatening some discoveries a lot
of them actually
but here it's a completely lost position
and on an off chance you haven't seen
this game feel free to pause the video
and find the winning move for Caruana
here it's not extremely complicated but
you know you so good it's a good
exercise for endgame skills so for those
of you who managed to find a move
congratulations you are an excellent
endgame player and for those who just
want to enjoy the show
here Bobby played rook to a1 check you
have to move King to c2 only square as
the bishop
covering b2 and now rook captures on d1
and this is something chronic obviously
missed as you can't capture the rook
back if you play King capture some D 1
then H 2 is coming and there is no
stopping the past H pawn rook h6 and now
Bishop to h4 simply covering up the pawn
as the nice protects the bishop on h4 so
here chronic saw that he just blundered
the rope he can't capture it back
he tried Bishop to a6 maybe some Bishop
to b7 check ideas picking up the night
and maybe guarding h1 I mean it's a move
but it doesn't help
rook to D to check by Fabi King to c1
and here we have Bishop to b2 check King
b1 and now simply the cold-blooded King
captures on c5 not giving white any
chances whatsoever even though even
though he's up a piece Bishop to b7 now
935 rook to f4 a rope to f6 and now f3
and it was in this position that allowed
me a chronic resigns at the game as
there is really nothing to do here here
rook no sorry it wasn't I believe on f3
rook to f5 pinning the knight was played
and here after f2 the game was resigned
but it doesn't matter you can also play
Bishop captures on f3 it doesn't help
you after Knight captures rook captures
on f3 Rock d1 check simply decides the
game you captured a bishop now h2
there's no stopping the pawn so I mean
anything was winning here it's simply
too good of a position for black so yeah
that's the game a very exciting thriller
from Round 4 would a lot of turnarounds
and it's I mean that that end game
between Oregon and kurakin was was
almost two engines playing and here we
have Fabiano and Kramnik playing an
endgame and it's like one moment this
player is winning one more moment death
Larry's winning and it's a hard hard to
imagine this after all it was a rest day
so here we have a couple of more photos
by Nikki here we have this is them
an interview after the game witness with
Nastasia Karlovic and here we have two
two more photos of Vladimir Kramnik
where you can see how very very
shattered he is it's like he's been
through a war here we have another one
that's that's a really good one here
he's totally totally not impressed with
his performance and and how how would he
be playing a game like that against our
own gun in round three and then losing a
game with white like this in Game four
but yeah a great game nevertheless and I
believe after four rounds Fabiano
Caruana
takes the lead in this tournament with
three and a half points out of four and
I I didn't prepare the standings for you
but I'll cover the grease chip game as
well so I will show you the standings in
that game as that game is really really
something so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it once again if you
enjoy photography if you enjoyed chess
if you enjoyed chess photography I have
feel free to follow Nikki on all of our
social media I will add all the links in
the description below so thank you all
for watching as usual you can check to
my previous videos here and I will see
you soon with the grist tube game thank
you all